tensions over taiwan have soared a visit
from house speaker nancy pelosi and
comments from other u.s officials about
the island have infuriated china
china this self-ruled island has grown
into a durable democracy and major
semiconductor producer
the us has promised to help it defend
itself
are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes but the problem is china
sees it as part of its own territory and
is threatened to seize it if necessary
over the past year the chinese military
has also sent
dozens of planes bombers and fighter
jets into the airspace close to taiwan
so as taiwan is perhaps the most
explosive issue in u.s china relations
here's how we got here and what's next
the first thing to know is that taiwan
which is located off china's coast has
been self-governed since 1949. that's
when the communist party took power in
mainland china and some nationalists
fled to the island
for china taiwan has seen as always been
the one that got away
when the chinese communist party first
founded the people's republic of china
taiwan was never part of the people's
republic instead it was governed by the
guamindan party
that had fled to the island after a
brutal civil war ever since then every
chinese leader has sought to reunify
taiwan with the mainland
and that includes president xi jinping
who has made bringing taiwan under
mainland control a key goal of his
legacy
but the us has shown support for
president
from beijing's perspective she's a
leader who is dangerously pushing taiwan
closer to independence
taiwan became a bigger bilateral issue
between the u.s and china during the
administration of president trump
what president donald trump did was to
make it part of u.s policy to tighten
ties with taiwan and this has continued
under president biden
for decades the u.s has sent weapons and
more recently has sent troops to provide
military training despite china's
warnings
the u.s has a few reasons to do that
firstly it's the u.s ninth largest
trading partner and taiwan is also a key
part of global supply chains taiwan is
also a litmus test for u.s credibility
in the region because the u.s allies
will watch u.s treatment of taiwan
carefully
one reason taiwan is so strategic for
the us and china is the role it plays in
manufacturing it's home to the world's
most critical chip maker and
semiconductors have been in short supply
over the past year
so what's next china has made a series
of moves in the region in what taiwan
sees as attempts to discourage the
island from forging closer ties with the
u.s and other allies
what we've seen is a pla unit posting on
its social media account the video of a
recent military drill that happened off
the coast of southeastern fujian
province and facing taiwan
the caption of the video read we're
ready to fight anytime
china also said it would hold live fire
military drills around taiwan in early
august
but this doesn't mean china will
actually invade the island which carries
a lot of risk considering washington's
pledges to help taiwan defend itself
taiwan is one of a number of issues such
as trade and technology that have soured
us china relations in recent years
despite the risks of escalation the u.s
is signaling that even with war raging
in ukraine it can remain very active in
the strategic asia-pacific region if the
u.s doesn't stand up for taiwan in the
face of china coercion
then u.s credibility in the region
suffers
and it would affect its relationship
with other allies in the region